on home pay of that Nvidia Alston she
had politically with the entitlement
interesting knock per shaft and if
toponyms and especially if it's a
president in the Commission for
mogherini the common hjerson love them
as much entities let's demolished the
system faucet suburban situation is
admission and and limine and darvid
certain nobility his mouth a fabric tab
thought the occupying of garden only
theory our protagonist Marrakesh
parlamento Scott escape tab here to dunk
it is a our pet monkey represent iam
house see hunters what
thank you very much mr. president thank
you also for your very kind words indeed
I was first of all I was thinking I
think it's the third or fourth time I
say goodbye to the semi cycle either
here or in Brussels but indeed it's a
pleasure to be back still for the last
session in which I will be in office and
just to reassure you not only I'll take
the debates today tonight but also the
urgencies tomorrow and the votes
tomorrow so I'll be there until the very
last moment I could and that is indeed
somehow a sign of dedication and the
recognition of the work that this
Parliament is doing in particular on
foreign policy and let me also thank you
for the opportunity with this debate to
look back at this five years of work
with our Eastern partners I remember
very well when I took office in 2014
that was the most important element of
our foreign and security policy agenda
for sure and I can now proudly say that
we have become closer as the European
Union to all our it's the partners to
all the six of them in different ways
and I believe we have managed to improve
the situation of each and every of them
in this partnership and through this
partnership even if obviously challenges
remains and I will go through I will try
to go short briefly through the
achievements the positive sights but
also the shortcomings and the things on
which we will I see that we will still
need to work a lot together I believe
that this positive path that we followed
has been possible because our work has
been focused always on our greatest
common interests that we share between
the European Union and our Eastern
partners and that is our people the
people of Europe whether they live
inside or outside the European Union
indeed the 20 deliverables that we are
implementing within the Eastern
Partnership focus on the issues our our
people care the most about drops energy
security education strong civil
independent media things that are indeed
on top of our citizens agendas in these
years we have put in place ambitious
association agreements and free trade
areas with Georgia with Moldova and
Ukraine their citizens can now also
travel to the European Union without a
visa when they come for business for
tourism or to visit family we've also
achieved good progress in trade energy
connectivity or the digital sphere at
the same time we need to do more in the
fields of rule of law judiciary and
fighting corruption earlier this year we
have celebrated the 10th anniversary of
the Eastern Partnership together with
our partners and we decided to launch a
broad consultation process on the future
of this partnership we have collected
now more than 200 contributions coming
not only from governments and civil
society but also academia the business
community members of the European
Parliament and other stakeholders and I
want to thank you for the contributions
you have given us so I am proud I can
now leave to you and to my successor
this huge capital of ideas achievements
but also aspirations and dreams as a
very solid foundation for the next
Eastern Partnership summit and for the
future of our partnership itself of
course each of the six countries has a
different situation and different
aspirations too so let me very briefly
go through them Ukraine has faced
unparalleled challenges with Russia's
violation of Ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity since 2014 we have
put together for Ukraine the biggest
support package in the history of the
European Union we have invested more in
Ukraine than in any other country in the
world and no other partner has invested
in Ukraine as much as we have done this
has led to some very important tangible
results I would say that Ukraine today
is a stronger more resilient country
than it used to be the new government
has taken a bold approach to reforms as
the people of Ukraine expect substantial
change on the rule of law on the fight
against corruption
and the prosecution of the backfloat in
recent months positive developments have
also materialized on the security sites
mainly thanks to Ukraine's constructive
approach and the Normandy for summit on
the 9th of December is now an
opportunity for substantial progress our
priorities are the same as those of our
friends in the Eastern Partnership
countries meet security good jobs put
governance or institutions that they can
trust and rely on this is also the case
in the Republic of Moldova where we have
supported structural reforms to fight
corruption improve the electoral
framework and to ensure an independent
and accountable justice system Moldova
has now in your governments and the need
for genuine reforms remains as always
the European Union is ready to support
reforms in all possible ways and as
always our support remains conditioner
our support is and I believe will
continue to be focused in particular on
reforms to fight corruption and vested
interests and in ensuring that state
institutions preserve or rather
sometimes build the autonomy and are not
politicized moving to Armenia the
government has committed to substantial
democratic reforms in line with our
partnership agreements in fact Amenia
considers the agreement with the
European Union as a true blueprint for
reforms and we are proud of that our
support to the reform process has
increased after last year's political
revolution including to the ALP to the
ongoing justice reform and I'm confident
that this partnership will become even
closer in the years ahead without
thereby join the work continues in order
to finalize a new agreement we want an
ambitious agreement in line with
international standards one that ranges
from human rights to the support of the
diversification of their economy we will
also continue to work for the peaceful
resolution of the nagorno-karabakh
conflict encouraging and supporting
dialogue at the highest level between
Armenia and Azerbaijan the fully
supports the mediation efforts ends the
proposals of the u.s. see Minsk Group
co-chairs including through the work of
our Special Representative the European
Union is born as a Peace Project
building peace is our DNA is our reason
that it goes to the core of who we are
we need I believe to continue investing
enormous Lee on this as conflict has not
yet disappeared from our continent on
the contrary the security situation
along the administrative boundary line
with the Georgian breakaway region of
South Ossetia has worsened in recent
months this is why we are increasing our
EU monitoring missions presence on the
grounds because our support to Georgia's
sovereignty and territorial integrity
it's not just a statement or a
declaration of principle is the
foundation of our daily concrete work on
the ground Georgia is a close and
reliable ally in the neighborhood in our
partnership and this is precisely why we
don't shy away when we see risks as
today we see the risk in the country of
a backsliding on some important reforms
in the rule of law area finally on
Belarus the recent parliamentary
elections were somehow a lost
opportunity to deliver on international
standards and we have called on the
authorities to implement electoral
reforms before next year's presidential
elections you all know that we have
divergences with Belarus particularly on
human rights yet I'm convinced the only
way forward is to continue engaging and
to finalize our partnership priorities
this would be the best way not only to
work on our mutual interests such as the
economy or nuclear safety but also to
better address the human rights
situation which is so important for us
so putting people first was our approach
throughout the five these five years
with all the six partners as diverse as
they are with a differentiated approach
respectfully and we've always focused on
people and not on geopolitics and I want
to close on this to stress once again
something that I have discussed several
times not only with our partners in the
east of Europe but also to our
interlocutors little bit further east
explaining clearly that our Eastern
Partnership is not and I believe will
never be against anyone it's for
it's for our people it's for improving
living standards including Democratic
standards for more peaceful european
continent's based on partnership and
cooperation and i want to close my short
remarks thanking you and this parliament
for all the support you have given to
our work with our Eastern partners
because in particular in this field the
work of the parliament has been key in
liaison with the national parliaments
through your many delegations through
your many visits and this has been a
fundamental pillar in accompanying our
work with not only the institutions but
also the societies of our six Eastern
partners thank you
[Applause]